stop wasting your breath start working
on your own party you start working on
your own issues and see whether you can
take my votes in the actual arena of
ideas it's no China shitty
last night at about midnight Eastern
time when much of the country was coming
to the slow dawning realization that the
next president United States would be
Donald Trump my guest here Nicolas our
work chair of the Libertarian Party was
saying it to the major parties your
tears are delicious well you know what I
say to that your tears are delicious and
your parties will die
[Applause]
it will Sarek welcome the morning after
out the election
thanks Matt you're left out the second
line and your parties will die that's
correct
well you know we didn't get a lot of
sleep last night here explain to the
world that's waking up a lot of people
everyone has Facebook friends here
people in your party in the campaign
last night we're all complaining about
their Facebook friends blaming them for
the election explain why you will feel
that their tears are delicious this
morning because the libertarian vote
which was a record it was over 4 million
votes for governor Gary Johnson which to
put in perspective it's about the same
number of votes that were cast in the
state of Virginia a state that carries
13 electoral votes that's the size of
the libertarian bloc those are people
who are not going to vote for a
warmonger they're not going to vote for
a corrupt corporate crony they're not
going to vote for someone who'll
continue to pursue the war on drugs or
continue to spend our country into
oblivion they're stepping outside of
that politics of fear and they're saying
I'm not participating in your clown show
and that's why it's so comforting to be
a libertarian today because it's their
fault if you run bad candidates you'll
lose if you don't address libertarian
ideas you'll lose that's just how it
works a lot of people will be waking up
and saying okay you love freedom you are
against authoritarianism and statism and
because you were on the ballot Donald
Trump is the president who is the most
authoritarian in status
fill-in-the-blank we've ever seen in our
lives how do you respond to that as a
libertarian I believe in personal
responsibility so blaming other people
for your failings is not really
something I'm on board with so I don't
respond to that talk about what happened
yesterday in terms of the party you've
said before that so you've gotten to
three million four million votes 3.7% is
somewhere in the high threes I couldn't
do the math and morning either I was
drinking a lot really and which is up
from one point you know Oh percent last
time point nine nine point nine nine
percent last time what happened on the
state-by-state level that you are
particularly happy about
this morning so as you probably know
during this election cycle we spent
about three-quarters of a million
dollars to get our candidate on the
ballot in all 50 states because there
are still 17 states where we don't have
the same ballot access footing the
Republicans and Democrats have every
ballot access win last night puts some
of that three-quarters of a million
dollars back in the coffers to actually
run candidates and campaigns rather than
spend it on petition signatures and
standing out in the rain bugging people
to let us have a seat at the table the
biggest wins last night Oklahoma where
we spent a hundred and five thousand
dollars to be on the ballot for the
first time since the year 2000 so that's
like nearly 20 percent of your money 15
percent of your money was just in one
state one state that we had left alone
for 16 years because it was that
expensive and that difficult we retained
ballot access handily there so the
Oklahoma Libertarian Party will remain
strong going forward and we won't have
to spend a dollar in Oklahoma on that
and to make people understand than me
too
so we're not just talking about the
presidential race in 2020 you're talking
about every single race statewide you
don't have to spend that time and money
Act where we ran candidates up and down
the ballot in Oklahoma you know from a
standing start this election cycle so I
expect in the midterms in 2018 will be
much more of a force to be reckoned with
there I was 16 years ago I was the
morning after the election I was in
Washington DC talking with Ralph Nader
and people around the Green Party who
were saying you know this is just the
beginning of a new thing for the Green
Party we're really going to go forward
from here on out we're gonna build on
2.7 percent of the vote we're gonna be
the third party in the United States
didn't happen that way a lot of people
were in the electorate were blamed Ralph
Nader for Florida blame Brown for the
election and it kind of collapsed how do
you tell yourself or how do you feel
about you know is the Libertarian Party
we're the Green Party was in 2000 are
you are you setting yourself up for a
fall as people wake up the next day and
say oh [ __ ] what do we do now
libertarians don't feel guilty about
this and that's the beauty of it
is a libertarian and that's sort of sad
for the Green Party because today
there's going to be a bunch of Democrats
who are gonna be yelling at their Green
Party friends about how they're traitors
to the cause and they're the reason that
we don't have the first woman president
all sorts of other just nonsense and
they'll probably listen because the
Green Party has this problem where
they're aligned with one of the two old
parties very closely and so they're
they're susceptible to that guilt-trip
in a way libertarians just aren't we
believe in freedom and the two old
parties don't so you can yell at me all
day long but I'm not supporting a war
monger I'm not supporting a corrupt
corporate crony and it's never gonna
happen so you should probably just waste
you know stop wasting your breath
start working on your own party start
working on your own issues and see
whether you can take my votes in the
actual you know arena of ideas instead
of trying to shame me and you guys
competed against the Green Party in
every state and Gary Johnson got more
votes than the Green Party nominee for
president in every state and the
District of Columbia which typically is
a stronghold for them are you confident
right now that the Libertarian Party is
the third party in the United States
absolutely we are the only political
party in the country that's growing I
think that's still the case after last
night's results I haven't seen the voter
registration numbers but looking at the
vote totals for the popular vote voter
turnout was actually down in this
election I think from previous votes in
this country and our numbers tripled
so it's a lot of math to do on a morning
after a big election night party but
that sounds good to me it sounds it
sounds a reasonably good I know you're
the chair of the Libertarian Party so
you don't spend a lot of time worrying
about the other parties but looking at
the Republicans right now there are a
lot of people who the rubble comes just
won a big election and they're in
complete chaos and there are a lot of
people talking about a Republican civil
war there how do you see that going
forward in their party and then what
might be the impacts on the Libertarian
Party it's not clear yet what's gonna
happen
I saw the Speaker of the House this
morning with way too much makeup on
trying to put on a brave face
on the whole thing and crowing about
success there are some possibilities for
some good policy to come out I know
people were very optimistic when George
W Bush had both houses of Congress that
you would get these traditional
Republican things would happen you know
lower taxes and all that stuff and that
didn't work out so well but it does seem
like there may be a mandate to get rid
of Obamacare which has been just a
terrible failure I live in Arizona I
have a business in Arizona my employees
can't afford to buy insurance our
premiums are going up by over a hundred
percent and that's considered a success
by the current administration that
cannot stand so maybe some good will
come out of it
we're gonna wait and see and you know
we're equal-opportunity where we're not
aligned to either of the two old parties
so we'll look for good freedom
supporting legislation and we'll back
those things on policy grounds and we'll
call out when you know either the old
parties don't live up to their ideals
which probably a lot more calling out
than backing last night on the stage I
think you said that the work now begins
today what happens with the Libertarian
Party between now and 2018 let's say
what is the tangible stuff that the lp
is doing we'll get ballot access back
for the Libertarian Party in Ohio in
Ohio we had Gary Johnson on the ballot
but he was on as an independent due to
some cheating by John Kasich that will
not stand
we'll go and recruit and run candidates
in Arizona where the Republicans passed
a law specifically aimed at ins in the
legislative history we have testimony
aimed at libertarians to try and keep us
off the ballot and yeah they kept most
of us off the ballot in 2016 but 2018 is
going to be a fun year for them to find
out what happens when you knock us down
punching porcupines is not a good
strategy last night also from the stage
you said that this is the most that's
the best ticket we've ever had that is
an item of some dispute among
libertarians of both capital and small-l
variety do you stand by that assertion
on the morning after I do I mean what
how is it in dispute we
tripled our vote totals in 2012 we've
had our record vote number in the
popular vote we we control a block of
the electorate that covers the spread in
almost all if not all of the
battleground states we've beaten the
other third party that you know even
sort of exists in this country in every
single state we were on the same ballot
how is that a problem
I I have I don't understand I mean there
are still trolls on Twitter who are
calling for my resignation today because
we got three point five percent of the
vote instead of five percent you know
I'm not gonna take success metrics from
people who are haters that's just not
how I live my life all right Nicholas or
chairman Liu from your party thank you
very much for joining us for reason TV I
am Matt Welch
[Music]